so everybody's talking about 19 Kids and
Counting the Duggar family one of the
sons molested some of the daughters I
don't watch the show I have literally
never watched the show I hate all of
those shows but sometimes out of these
shows percolates a story that has a
bigger significance and I think this is
one of those what I think is interesting
about this now this family particularly
because there was such this moral high
ground with them right and telling
people that gay marriage is no good
meanwhile the Sun is literally molesting
the daughter like his own sister but
these were people that were playing some
sort of moral high ground game and of
course most times this happens
constantly our politicians who are
against gay marriage are getting
[ __ ] in bathrooms in Minnesota
airports right we hear this all the time
these preachers it's always with the gay
thing for some reason if you're a DJ
you're pretty much doing gay stuff I
mean it'sit's psych 101 kind of stuff
but I think the more interesting piece
of this is why do we put people on
television and on the screen on these
high pedestals I really don't understand
I think at some point it did make sense
somewhere along the road you know like
we had people that were in TV and movies
and they wanted to use their voice to
talk about things that they care about
and I think that worked for a long time
and then when reality TV came out we put
people with no discernible talents or
skills on television to expose
themselves to rant and rave and and to
somehow lead what this country's pop
culture something or other became it's
all kind of gross and we have alien
examples of this from duck dynasty and
the oldest duck he doesn't you know he'd
what's the deal he doesn't like gay
people this is a guy who made his living
on selling something that you blow that
makes a duck sound so that you saw a
duck wants to have sex with another duck
and then he shoots both ducks or
something along those lines by the way
when that guy did that whole thing just
for a little free speech portion of this
I was not for him getting fired because
people have free speech if a any or
whatever channel was wanted to fire him
then so be it but
you can say whatever you want and then
people like me have the right to
relentlessly mock you for anyway we got
people like duck dynasty talking about
morals we got the Kardashians who girls
right now there's a trend on Twitter
where girls are doing some weird crap to
their lips to make their lips look as
juicy a plump as the Kardashians I mean
awful stuff we just got these people who
are nothing but attention [ __ ] this
whole group of attention [ __ ] with
again no discernible talent and they
preach to us and they push their crap
and it makes it feel like we're all part
of it but we're really not we're really
not you're not part of it I'm not part
of it i feel gross talking about it so
hopefully this is the last time i hear
anything about the Duggars the
Kardashians the Robertsons or what about
that Jersey guy with ads I don't like
him either anyway what do you think let
me know your thoughts in the comments